لا ، نحن بحاجة إلى أسئلة
[موسيقى]
ولكن إذا كان السؤال سيئ التجهيز
وسوء التنظيم وكان الطلاب
عالقين هنا خلال الأيام الأربعة الماضية ،
فلا يمكن الوصول إلى الطعام ولا الوصول إلى
المياه النظيفة ولا الكهرباء ولا شيء ،
وحتى كما نجلس هنا تقريبًا
في كل مكان يمكنك سماع طلقات نارية ، فنحن
لسنا بأمان ،
شكرًا لك ،
لذا فإن الأحدث هنا مثل أننا أمضينا أيامًا
دون أن نأخذ عدم وجود حمامات كافية ، ولا مياه كافية ، ولا
ماء ، ولا شيء على الإطلاق ، لا شيء على الإطلاق ، لا شيء ، لا شيء على الإطلاق ، لا
شيء في
مقر الجامعة ، كما
تعلمون خارج مقر الجامعة
وما هو  يحدث الأمر وكأنهم
يأخذوننا كحماية كدرع
لذلك لأنهم يعرفون أنه إذا كانوا
بالقرب من الطالب فلن يكون هناك
أي قصف
[موسيقى]